. UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS WERE HERE AGAIN
SOME OF YOU THOUGHT YESTERDAY
WAS OUR LAST MEETING. SOMETHING
TELLS ME WE MIGHT BE BACK.
EITHER WAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
THREE BILLS TODAY A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX SB FORTY
NINE. AND SB FIVE SIXTY AND IN
REGARDS TO A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SIX I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE MISTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE HERE
TO PRESENT ON THIS BILL TO THE.
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE-
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL THE
REQUESTED. THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION TO. HOLD THE COMMITTEE
HOLD THE BILL IN COMMITTEE MAKE
IT TO YOUR BILL. AND I JUST
WANTED TO. I EITHER HIT CERTAIN
STRUCTURES ARE TO REQUEST YES
SIR I'VE NEVER SAID THIS BEFORE
BUT I WOULD LIKE YOU PLEASE TO
HOLD THE BILL MAKE IT TO YOUR
BILL WE ARE NEGOTIATING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND I WOULD LIKE
TO PUT THAT BACK UP NEXT YEAR.
OKAY FANTASTIC. FIRST OF ALL
I'M SORRY WE- WERE JUST TO
NOTICE RESTARTING THE
COMMITTEE. WERE BEGINNING A AS
THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH TO CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HUESO.
PRESENT HUESO PRESENT MORE LACK
BRADFORD. REDFORD HERE CHIANG
CHING HERE DODD YOUR GUIDE HERE
HERTZBERG. HEALTH CARE HILL
HERE MCGUIRE RUBIO RUBIO HERE
SKINNER. ENTER HERE STERN STERN
HERE STONE WIENER. MORE LIKE
PRESENT MORE LIKE PRESENT. EN
OKAY SO ON THIS BILL I'M SORRY
IF YOU COULD JUST REQUEST THAT
AGAIN. A YES SIR WE ARE STILL
NEGOTIATING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WE ARE REQUESTING THAT YOU HOLD
THE BILL AND MAKE IT INTO YOUR
BILLS WE CAN CONTINUE NEXT
YEAR. OKAY MOTION ANYONE. WE
HAVE A MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DOES ANYBODY THE PUBLIC WANT TO
COMMENT ON THIS. ANYONE AT ALL.
ANYONE NOBODY'S INTERESTED WE
HAVE A MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
THAT THE MEASURE BE HELD IN
COMMITTEE PURSUANT TO SENATE
ROLE TWENTY NINE POINT TEN.
WEST SO I WAS SO I AM MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
I'D CHIANG CHING AYE DODD DODD
AYE HERTZBERG HILL BY HILL AYE
MCGUIRE. RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN. AN
ICE DOWN WIENER WIENER AYE. THE
NUMBER ZERO HOLD THE ROLE OF
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER. ON A
SB FORTY NINE SENATORS SKINNER.
YEAH. I NEVER TRIED THIS.
EVERYTHING THIS TIME OF YEAR
OKAY. THANK YOU I'M MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. WITH THIS IS
BACK BEFORE YOU BECAUSE IN THE
ASSEMBLY IT WAS AMENDED TO
ALLOW FOR THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY TO ALSO LOOK AT.
POSSIBLE DEMANDMANAGEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN OUR WATER
ROME THE WATER PROJECT AND JUST
AS A BRIEF BRIEF REMINDER WHAT
THIS BILL IN ITS CORE DOES IS
ALLOW OUR ENERGY COMMISSION TO
HELP. TO HELP SUPPORT THE SMART
APPLIANCES AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN HELP ALL
OF US DO BETTER DEMAND
MANAGEMENT MEANING USE
ELECTRICITY EITHER AT THE POINT
WHERE IT IS CHEAPEST OR WERE
THE POINT WHERE ARE RENEWABLE
ENERGY IS GENERATING THE MOST
SO DEMAND MANAGEMENT CAN REALLY
HELP US IN TERMS OF GRID
STABILITY AND EVEN HELP MEAN
CUSTOMERS LOWER THEIR COSTS.
NOW ON THE WATERFRONT I DEMAND
MANAGEMENT OF WATER IS ALSO
SMART BECAUSE WATER IS A
SIGNIFICANT ENERGY USER IN THIS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN OTHER WORDS ALL THE
PROCESSING TREATING PUMPING
EXETER OF WATER. SO WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF. MEMBERS LET'S
GO TO THE PUBLIC FIRST. BUT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ WITH
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOUR MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA DEVELOPED
TECHNET IN SUPPORT. FIFTY VAN
HAVE A CALIFORNIA FISSION SEE
AND TO MANAGER CUTS ONCE PART.
ANYONE ELSE ANY OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION. CAN SOMEBODY COULD
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION BILL ANYONE
NOT. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THE BILL. ANYONE ELSE WILL
MOTION CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PERCENT TO TWENTY NINE
POINT TEN D. THAT THEY ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE KURT IN WEST
SO. BY WAS SO I MORE LOCK.
BRADFORD. CHANG CHANG AYE DODD
AYE DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL
WELL I MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
STONE. NO NO WIENER WIENER AYE.
BRADFORD I. ALL THE ROLE FOR
FRANCE MEMBERS OR DO WE HAVE A.
WHERE EUROPE. SB FIVE SIXTY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISTER
CHAIR IN MEMBERS SB FIVE SIX
HE'S COMING TO THE SENATE OFF
OF A VERY CLOSE VOTE NEED
SIMPLY SEVENTY NINE ZERO FIRST
OF ALL I WILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
IT'S THE FIVE SIXTY IS A SIMPLE
STEP TO MITIGATE THE RISKS
DURING TIMES OF CRISIS
ESPECIALLY DURING PUBLIC POWER
SHUT OFF IT WOULD ENSURE THAT
OUR STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS AS WELL AS ALL
HOSPITALS HAVE THE CRUCIAL
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
RESPOND D. G. ENERGIZING EVENTS
MANDATING COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE UTILITIES AND THOSE FIRST
RESPONDERS I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY. REST NOVAK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN COURSE OF ZERO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THEIR SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR RUSSELL NOVAK COMING UP
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MA'AM IT'S
MAKE IT EVEN EVEN CLEARER THAT
DURING THESE DEANDRE ZHAI'S
SCENE PROSPECTS CERTAINLY
DURING OUT DURING DISASTER
RELATED INCIDENCES THAT THE
INFORMATION THE NOTICES
PROVIDED ON A ON A- EXPEDITIOUS
BASIS FOR FIRST RESPONDERS. BUT
TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND AND ALSO
TO COORDINATE COMMUNICATION
THROUGHOUT THE EVENT WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MEMBERS COREY SAYS ONLY
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN THE INTEREST OF
BREVITY AND HEARING THE MOTION
BEING MADE I WOULD ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE FIRE CHIEFS AND THE AUTHOR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OTHERS SPEAKERS AS PART GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TEN MEMBERS
CAROLING ABOVE. OF THE
MENDOCINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND STRONG SPORTS I
THINK YOU. IT'S CHAIR MEMBERS
GRECO COVERS INTO THE
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN GOLD
STATE POWER COOPERATIVE IN
SUPPORT. ANYWAY ALSO SUPPORT
ANYONE OPPOSITION. THE BILL
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR
STONE ANYONE HERE OKAY LOOK
PLEASE CALL. SB 560% TO TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN D. THAT THE
ASSEMBLYMAN SPEAKING CURTAIN
MYSELF FIVE WHAT'S SO I'M A
LOT. MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHING CHANG I GOD HI
DODD AYE HERTZBERG THOUGH.
HEARD ALREADY NOTIFIED. THE
ROLE ON THE BILL WILL TAKE UP
FOR THE FOR SIDE OF AID THE
THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX TO MAKE IT A
TO YOUR BILL. THE CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS. THIS
WILL AND CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
THAT THE MEASURE BE HELD IN
COMMITTEE. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE STONE
AYE STONE AYE. THE BILL THE
BILL IN COMMITTEE. WILL GO TO
SB FORTY NINE. PLEASE CALL THE
UPS MEMBERS. THAT THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SPEAKING PART
IN THE CURRENT VOTE CAN ONE
MOORLACH. HERTZBERG I. OKAY
YEAH. WE. THAT BILL AND IS OUT
OF COMMITTEE. YEAH. WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. HELLO. THAT IS LATER
ON WHY IS IT LATER. WE HAVE TO
COME BACK. WE ARE NOT TURNED
UNTIL LATER IN THE DAY.